-Kenya Barris, welcome back
to "The Tonight Show."
Thanks for being here.
I want to talk to you about --
I want to talk to you
about "You People."
-Oh, thank you.
-Eddie -- Congratulations.
-Oh, thanks.
-Eddie Murphy, Jonah Hill.
It's great.
I want to get into all that.
But, first, you were telling me
about a movie you're doing now
backstage.
You're working on a new film.
-Yes.
-And can we talk about this?
-Yeah, let's talk about it.
-It's a --
It's kind of a reimagining
of "The Wizard of Oz."
-Yeah.
-That's a big thing.
-It's a big deal. [ Laughs ]
-It's a big deal.
How did you end up there,
and how are you gonna do this?
-I wanted to --
me and Rashida Jones,
who's my sister --
we wanted to do "The Wiz."
-Yeah.
-And, you know,
her dad did the music for it,
and we thought
it would be great.
And we went to --
the studio who owns the --
who owns "The Wiz,"
which is --
probably this studio --
and I love --
I love the people,
but they were kind of hedging.
And then we realized they were
never going to let us do it,
because they had "Wicked"
coming out,
and they had invested
so much money in "Wicked."
-Oh, yeah.
-And so we went to Warner Bros.
And she had to go do some --
make a ton of money
doing some shows or whatever.
But I really wanted to do it.
And Toby Emmerich,
who was running Warner Bros.
at the time,
that was his favorite movie.
And I gave him my pitch of,
like, I think "The Wizard of Oz"
back in the day was like --
it turned a mirror.
It was like the Dust Bowl,
Great Depression era,
and it turned a mirror on, like,
society.
That's what it was about.
It was, like, talking about
self-reliance
and things like that.
I think that this is
the best time
to turn a mirror on society,
because we need to see ourself.
And I was, like, I want to do it
with diverse characters,
and I really want to sort of,
you know -- she lives --
the character lives in Inglewood
and something comes up
and she ends up in Underhood,
which is right outside...
[ Light laughter ]
...outside of Oz.
And it takes place from there.
And I'm doing it
with these guys,
1500 or Nothin' --
like, amazing musicians.
And -- But we're writing it
with the music as I'm writing,
because I feel like
it's the only movie
where each song tells you
what's about to happen.
You know what I'm saying?
-Yeah.
-"We're off to see --"
and I saw --
-Yeah,
"We're off to see the Wizard."
-So literally, like,
hearing, like --
I didn't realize how melodic
"Somewhere Over the Rainbow"
was, that you --
you know what I'm saying?
So, like, they're giving me
different motifs.
And like, I've never --
it's all --
-Have you ever written
like that before?
-[ Sighs ] No, but I actually
worked with your guys,
and we did an amazing
Juneteenth musical.
And I realized, like, it was --
it was something I wanted to do.
-Yeah.
It was something
I really wanted.
I wanted to, like,
make people think,
but, also, make 'em feel good
and also make people feel seen
who hadn't been seen, so...
-Good for you, bud.
-Yeah.
-Come on. You keep crushing --
keep hitting homers, man.
Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's talk about
your new comedy,
a new comedy film.
By the way, first of all,
a new comedy film!
-[ Laughs ] No comedies.
-No one makes comedies anymore.
Let's make a comedy film.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's go support a comedy.
"You People."
You're getting great reviews,
buddy.
Here's one from Deadline --
said, "Eddie Murphy,
Julia Louis-Dreyfus,
Jonah Hill
lead Kenya Barris'
hysterically funny and smart
feature debut."
Congratulations, come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you so much.
-Dude, rave reviews.
-Rave reviews.
-You co-wrote the script
with Jonah Hill...
-Yeah.
-...who's very funny,
one of our favorites --
very funny in this movie.
How did you guys get together?
-So, I've been a fan
of Jonah's forever.
You know what I'm saying?
Like, you know, I grew up
with those Apatow films,
and you know what I'm saying?
-He's unbelievable.
-"Freaks and Geeks"
and all this stuff.
And we --
I really started getting,
you know, started talking a lot
when he did "Mid90s."
'Cause I was like,
"Bro, you killed it."
-Oh, that was great.
-He killed it.
And I was -- So, we, you know,
he was, like, telling me
he likes the stuff that I do.
He's like --
He likes talking about stuff.
He's like -- He has an idea.
And we -- So it was supposed
to be a 30-minute meeting --
ended up being three hours
that led to two weeks
of us putting together a pitch,
and we --
you know, he was dating
this Colombian girl,
and he talked about, like,
it's not the people
who usually are the problem --
it's the people around them
that are the problem.
And then we started talking
about, you know,
Jewish families
and Black families,
it's like
the Oppression Olympics.
You know what I'm saying?
Like, who had it --
-"The Oppression Olympics."
-Who had it worse?
And we just, literally --
Like, the point for me --
like, we're both L.A. kids.
I'm from a, you know,
predominantly
Black neighborhood --
he's from a predominantly white,
but the way L.A. geographically
is set up,
a lot of times, by the time
you get to high school,
you start mixing the kids --
you know what I'm saying?
And I started finding, like,
you know,
you have more in common
than you do not.
-Yeah.
-And so, we were, like,
let's just, you know,
make this a love letter to L.A.
Like, that really was,
like, you know,
one of the things
we wanted to do
is make it a love letter
to our culture,
and let's, you know, make it
a love letter to love.
-Yeah.
-And so, I think
that's what we tried
to set out and do.
And hopefully people, like, it
resonates and people get that.
-It has joke,
joke, joke, joke, joke.
I mean, it is -- Dude,
you came out punching, man.
-Yeah, we swung.
-Every second is a joke,
and it's, like, so good.
And Lauren London?
-She's the next --
she's Black Julia Roberts.
-She's unbelievable in this,
and that is a big discovery.
[ Applause ]
-You know, I feel like it is,
in our community,
in the Black community,
people -- she was --
she was ours.
You know what I'm saying?
And she had some traumatic
things in her life happen.
And I had to beg her to do this.
-She knocks it out of the park.
-She knocked --
And she's just --
I have this thing --
I think stars are stars
because there's like --
Julia Roberts, Sandra Bullock,
George Clooney, De Niro
says the same lines --
you basically --
they're basically the
same person, and you buy them.
That's what makes them a star,
something about them.
And I think something about
Lauren --
you just want her to win.
-Yeah.
-You want to root for her.
-I totally agree with you, yeah.
It's so funny.
How do we set up the movie?
-It's a love story.
Girl from
Inglewood/Baldwin Hills
whose family is Muslim
has a -- gets --
has a great meet-cute
with someone from a complete --
from Brentwood,
a completely different thing.
They come together.
They really fall for each other.
They fall for, like,
what love is really about --
like, just connection.
And they realize that the hurdle
is now going to be
their parents.
And that's where the show
kind of takes off.
-Yeah.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Jonah Hill
and Julia Louis-Dreyfus
in "You People."
Take a look.
-Everyone thinks I'm cool,
I'm hip.
-[ Sighs ]
-People think
I'm a very youthful person.
"I get it."
You know, you're
expressing yourself
with these illustrations,
graffiti all over your body.
Okay, fine.
But it is Yom Kippur,
God damn it.
-First of all, can you
please stop saying
"I get it" and using air quotes?
And second of all,
when someone says,
"I'm cool, I get it,"
they never are cool
and they never get it.
You shouldn't have to say that.
-That's not true in my case.
-You won't be able to be buried
in a Jewish cemetery.
-Bubbie, respectfully,
you can take my ashes,
and you can flush them
down the urinal
at Dodger Stadium, respectfully.
-What?
-Oh, so now you're
disrespecting the Dodgers?
-I-I wanna be buried
next to Rihanna.
-Rihanna? What do you --
-Yeah.
-Okay, I'm gonna scrape
those tattoos off myself,
and I'm gonna bury you
in a double-wide coffin with me.
Okay?
How about that?
-Sounds good.
-Yeah, sounds good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, have you --
I also should mention Mike Epps.
-Oh, my God.
-Mike Epps kills in every scene
in this movie.
-Oh, my God.
-That dude was on fire, man.
-Him and Deon Cole...
-Yeah.
-...are just like --
it was crazy,
because Eddie is everybody's --
like, you know,
all the comedians,
like, they look up to Eddie.
-Eddie Murphy.
-When Mike came,
he was especially --
he's like,
"I'm 'bout to show off."
You know what I'm saying?
And literally seeing them
together,
I feel like there's so much
on the cutting-room floor
that I one day want to put out.
It was --
You couldn't stop laughing.
Like, we -- we had to stop --
I had to, like, tell people,
"You've got to leave
if you can't stop laughing."
-And if you
can get Eddie Murphy to laugh,
it feels good.
-It feels like scoring
on Jordan.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-It does.
Kenya Barris, everybody.
"You People"
is in select theaters now,
premieres on Netflix
next Friday.
Go see a comedy
in a movie theater!
We'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show."
Stick around.
[ Cheers and applause ]